[拍手]
これじゃあ皆さん
私はミュージシャンです
日夜日々いろんなところで
そしてますとよく質問されることがありました
あのすみません
外国人の方ですか
ある
名前も方からですし
6もないかなぁと思うんですけれどもなにを隠そう
両親ともに本陣でしてい
新庄の手違いで様々ご利用使い分け
はい
me
wh
ni
me
[音楽]
re 品
me
よなん
音楽って楽しいと思いませんか
ああああああ
2位拍手を強要してしまったけど行けん
ネジあエンターテインメントに没頭しているミュージシャンから皆さん
人を楽しませること言って
本当にやりがいがあることだと思いませんか
バックアップしをやるさんですすいませんございました
チェジャ
人を楽しませるために私はいろんなところに行きます
ビアガーデンお待ち結婚式
アーリーとか各種イベント曲か
いろんなところで営巣しています
そして
いろんなところで
いろんな業種の人と関わっています
自治体とか法人とか会社とか組合とか
商店会の人とか
いろんな人と仕事をしている人
その人を楽しみましょうということを
音楽業界で言うか
ミュージシャンのことだけじゃないなんて思うようになりました
皆さん
今日はいい
いろんな仕事をしている人がいらっしゃると思いますけれども
例えば会社で上司の人とか部下の下とか同僚の人とか
お客様から取引先会社に喜んでもらえるということを
することは至極当たり前当然のことでありますけれども
今日はその一歩先にある楽しんでもらう
このことをこの概念を想像してみませんか
そうやっていろんな先ほど申し上げだと思う
いろんな人と価格
お仕事数
いろいろな社会の側面といっしょに仕事ですだからこそ
本当に楽しませるっていう
そこらじゅうにあるんだ思うようになりました
人を楽しませるってことは
とにかく
そういうえんだという目で追っての誠実体感
すごく
前向きなパワーの源です
皆さんが課税でも職場でも売っ
電源関係でも人を楽しませようとしているときにものすごいパワー
理由分かってんま割にすぎません
例えば
大切な人の
記念日誕生日ものを打ったりとかするほどよくありますよね
あれも相手に楽しんでもらおうと思ったことなので
エンターテインメントというのではないでしょう
それとデータの時に彼女もしくは
ある日のレイプするときに必ず毎回この日用意する
ig
一緒に歩いてて恥ずかしくないしてみたい
はた職場でいつもたっちゃうかっている美人のただろう
もう周りの同僚が感動するくらい事例の方つかつっていて
道具の一つ一つも泥子
もう仕事中もストレスを拭い参加の坊
そういった形で
やれども
バターンエンターテイメント
そして
これが3時間がレースと
あと親孝行なんかもえんだってイベントの可能性を秘めていますね
親孝行
ああいうの
私が例えば独身男性イチゴを彼女もいない
仮定します
もうやめたいじゃない
早く親に孫の顔を見せてあげて
これから
妖精楽しくそこしてもらえるようにしたいな
同氏はまず彼女を作るところ始めていけないから
合コン誰かダウンしてもらえますから
それで合コンダウンロードしてもらってで6たのは言うけど僕たちの探る母校咬み
合わせてそこから結婚まで持っていくタイプですよね
親族に会津てるとかいざ結婚した後も箱の妊活しなければいいん
その上で新しい命が誕生するとなったらそれに進めていろいろ
中火をしていかなければいけない
もう1年どころじゃ足りない壮大なるてきた一曲作のエンターテイメントの十分です
これはまあもうすぐ何がいいたいかと
言いますですね
それから能動的に行動することこそ
そうすることによって周りの環境とその人の周りの人をもちろん変わりますしそういっ
た変化の中から必ず自分の方に帰ってくる
余韻変化があるじゃないかなと
こうして考えてみるとエンターテイメントっていう
普段意識してないだけで皆さんの日常生活
すぐそこに皆さんがシールエンターテイメントかたくさんあると思いませんか
[拍手]
強く自分のプライベートパーティーなんかも読んでもらったりするんです
本当に個人のだけでも出張して
六花同意したりなんかしてい
[音楽]
ni
清楚選挙がずれましたはぁ
気分はすっかり
突撃隣の出張エルビスプレイ済みですけど
エピソードも三浦これ以上が伸びてこないんだよ
ちょっとされた意味はたれるんですけど恵比寿へ play つぐれい
ますおっ
まあ
それは酒酔い
皆さんそうやって自分がエンターテイメント前にへ
与えようという意識を持つことによって周りの変化がどんどんあってそれが自分に
リターンしていて人生が少しずつ
豊かな方向に変わっていく+も spiral スパイラルを作ることができたらそれ
は何と素晴らしいことか
いやいやもう自分は笑メニューとか
米ちゃんと違いますからそんなエンターテインメントの勉強な[ __ ]便をしたことなく
てそんな無理ですよ無理ですよという方がいらっしゃるかもしれません
ところが心配ご無用です
アイテム楽しんでもらおうと思って一生懸命やることが重要だと思いませんから
されて一生懸命やっている市西部から気持ちっていうの
周りの一人ビンビン伝わりますもし周りに皆さんがそういう気持ちの人がいからその心
役に
好感を持ちませんか
私もいくら実績と実があるミュージシャンでもやる気のない人と一緒に演奏するより
多少差なくてもお客さんで楽しんでるだろう
一緒にあっ
音楽やっている仲間に気持ちよく演奏してもらおうという心意気のある人と一緒に演奏
したいと思いますどうショット方がそうだと思います
そんなことがそんなことのほうが未来に貼ってんだと思いませんか
enter てベル
外人
本当に短いに入った
改めて
ジェンから自分スっ子で先の
技術
実績より
人の気持ちとか心っていうの
本当に人を感動するための三光堂
あ
もやっぱハートが肝心要だなぁ
これは何か曲ができちゃうなんかああ
早朝たなんかん
んだうん
ティっ日曜ああ
me
のっ
日本などでえっ4ああんんん
ええええええ
おそばっん
まあまあ
ハァハァ
[音楽]
あっはい
皆さんはチビの
生活の中でエンターテイイベントについてどうお感じていらっしゃいますでしょ
音楽以外でも
映画やお芝居演劇ダンスミュー時間
誰の上
お笑い
様々な年代で勉強会での中によって
テレビラジオ新聞雑誌
シーリー
といったものがそれを伝えます
今の世の中だったらインターネットか
その最もしたら情報源かも知れませんか
日常生活から遠く離れた所にある
そんな所で生成されたエンターテインメントがそういったな媒体を通して自分の日常に
運ばれていてすぐ近くに来ているので金日常のことだ
思ってしまっていませんか
愛知場から東空離れたところにあると思いがちなエンターテインメントがよくよく考え
てみると先ほど話したと言う
自分たちもすぐそばにあっ
笹谷ものから大きなものまで
そして者レニー点も
それに気付くことができてい
それを大切にしろという気持ちを持つこと
私はたまたま音楽という仕事をしているだけ
チビ司直果敢に音楽会ねー
人を楽しませる dirty イベントをやっていますけれども
いざ自分が仕事以外いっ
家族とか
10人関係とかで売っ
音楽以外にしてあげられるエンターテインメントがあるかなーと考えた時に
正直まだしたりない事柄とかやらなければいけないことがある
あーなんか見過ごしていることがあるなぁと
ここでスピーチしながら耳くん
ちょっと2がしてしまいます
皆さんも
ぜひ自分の持つエンターテインメントに磨きをかけ
それを発揮して
プラスのエネルギーをガーッと周りに踏まえてみませんか
そして
その縁談底面とで
まわりの人と
日常生活
環境と社会よ
世界を良い方向に変えて来ませんか
ni
[音楽]
me
ni
wh
ええええええ
あああああいいいい
ani
ni ん
[音楽]
[拍手]